tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo momento
sono fa vj e questo è un piccone che ho
fatto io sia in realtà non sono io che
metto i cappelli sono i cappelli che
mettono me
giuro i ragazzi prima di cominciare e
partire con la formale della settimana
che questa settimana è stata vinta da
maria che ha fatto reazioni non mi
ricordo stavo già messo staff spero di
no però l'avevo già vista da un pezzo
non mi ricordo se l'avevo messa nel coso
fatemi stuprare vivo da un bel po di
cappella ciao ragazzi prima di
cominciare a tanto i semi chiarirvi non
so se ve ne siete accorti ma questa non
è camera mia ecco mi sembra leggermente
a disagio a fare un video che non è in
camera mia lo dico veramente c'è una
roba perché ho sempre fatto vide in
camera mia
ma siccome ragazzi stavolta è sia sabato
che domenica solo fuori casa quindi non
potevo fare blog in camera ho dovuto
farlo qua per forza comunque non mi dico
dove sono una casa ci sono infatti in
una casa minchia iniziatore difatti se
torna nei padroni son cazzi prova non so
che la gente è diventata pigra quindi
gli alberi di natale scarseggiano questo
si sa però ma porchio troy si chiama
ragazzi non sono in camera mia
dell'unico video in assoluto che farò
non in camera mia non posso fare lo
scatto dei pacchi perché ovviamente non
è che mi sono portato 700 kg pacchi
anche perché sono entrato dalla finestra
quindi veniva difficile quindi ragazzi
che ho fatto l'altra volta deciso di
fare un fa vidi sponde unico così almeno
siamo a posto
news che volevo darvi ragazzi che in
realtà si come sta arrivando natale cioè
penso lo sappiamo tutti tranne chi ha
fatto questa altri come quei giorni sto
che i miei genitori non registrerò quei
giorni perché sto con loro quindi non è
che posso però cercherò di coprire tutto
quanto ragazze capita che per caso 12
giorno lo so che capiterà magari una
volta che non sia un video
sapete perché cioè non è che sono morto
con che ragazzi a parte questo ho finito
con le colleghe ed è un miracolo che non
ho parlato mezz'ora di news e dovete
ringraziare iddio e del dovere che
possiamo partire favi disponendola che
purtroppo non posso fare appunto l'ho
scartato di pacchi ma ho scelto
abbastanza domande guidati quanto cazzo
fa paura così
che bello adesso faccio tutto il blog
così no io mi diverto con poco mi state
prendendo per il va beh io io lascerei
perdere questa cosa che appena sociale
vabbè union style fa vigente toner da
ciò la merdaccia metti metti la sotto i
video sotto il nikkei non so leggere
potrei farlo volentieri però in teoria
la mia camera finirebbe tipo così quindi
non lo fa risponde favi che generi di
musica sguardo di là perché sono schermo
il ragazzino che possa oggi è così che
generi di musica ascolti a parte
skrillex skrillex io potrei commettere
un omicidio
adesso proprio scuri l'ex che cazzo ti
avrei mai ascolto a michael jackson pop
in generale però gesù santo iddio favi
domanda a me piacciono a me piacciono il
porno francia mi fa piacere che non
vedevo l'ora di saperla questo mi fa
piacere
non so cosa ci sta a fare se ti piace di
porno cosa ci fai sui miei video devo
iniziare a pensar male cioè che cos'è
che fight di preciso quando guardi i
miei video chiti e lola stube chi cazzo
di dovere alla fine gomito titoli aaa
allora avete presente quello che è
successo la settimana scorsa di
coriandoli ho detto che non ci avrei mai
fatta toglie agli infatti ho cambiato
camera non è più la camera mi ama e cae
cam era una persona camera cazzo perché
non potevo più stare in camera mia non
li ho tolti semplicemente a posto a
proposito di the walking dead perché non
fai una serie su questo gioco cielo o il
gioco di voti ne de mi piace anche un
casino non ho mai fatto il gioco perché
è diverso dei ministri allora i ragazzi
faccio giochi indie cioè nel senso
giochi dove posso scalzare dove posso
far battute lo posso ridere o
spaventarmi e non faccio mai giochi
narrativi perché devo chiedendo un gioco
molto e narrativo che a me piace un
casino cioè non fraintendete però non è
non è da fa vj c'è nel senso non so
spiegarlo non saprei non saprei
schiacciato
ho vomitato l'anima facendo così se
volete ragazzi posso provare a farlo
però non vi assicuro nulla perché non
sarebbe tanto famigli il solito fa vj e
quello che vi voglio dire per quello ho
anche un po di paura a farlo nel senso
non so se poi magari non piace io so
stay fobie ragazzo ha una paura assurda
di fare cose nuove perché non sono mai
come potreste prendere comunque so
gesticolando manco un make up antonino
menciassi buon natale caro amico buon
natale anche a te essi cazzi fa vi
risponde dato chiusi cuffie microfono e
webcam fai vedere 40 secondi tuoi
capelli fare rispondeva la [ __ ] volta
fai un video dedicato alle pagan sisters
e ai droni ps ti stuprerò stanotte
grazie dell'ultima dichiarazione non
dormo più tanto nel letto ci sto perché
c'è la merda belle tutti ragazzi venuti
a questa novità sui pony che bello spero
vi sia piaciuto veramente favismo anche
se dovessi a mangiare un unico cibo per
tutto il resto della tua vita quale
sarebbe forse la pizza non lo so
risponde far vivere un film al cinema e
poi esci e fai qualcosa
all'uscita io ho cercato di capire per
mezz'ora il senso di questa domanda e
non lo trova giura non l'ho trovato però
vabbè ragazzo non ci sono andata a
vedere b giro 6 al cinema che tanto il
figo ma veramente figo e hanno messo il
cell
la mia missione è andare a toccare il
pupazzo terminati
[Musica]
tommy bug poi risponde ti fa crescere la
barba
ok ci provo e cipro non lo so nota
sicuro niente però cipro kat sav i
disegni lab ha la barba devo disegnarmi
la barba ho trovato questo grazie a dio
non so dove
giuro che se non va via degli incontri
dopo da fare con amici dove anche magari
uscire se non si toglie che a marzo sono
una persona seria adesso posso uscire a
post grazie se non va via
le botte ragazzine che posso concludere
il video qua spero che vi sia piaciuto
né avrei fatto il video di sabato però
so che se non lo faccio poi voi ghigo e
la megane mimicry stonata addosso lo
faccio uguale anche se sono fuori casa
ghazi mi ammazzo ma lo faccio lo stesso
perché so che ci tenete in ogni modo
però se non mi va via io vi devo far
male prima di concludere ragazzi faccio
affari domanda come al solito che ed è
facile perché la prima come cazzo mi
tolgo questo vi do it dovete dirmi come
cazzo mi tolgo sta roba è la seconda
cosa ragazzi e che ci fa di preciso una
ciabatta in questo punto del letto cosa
non mi fa paura da quando ho iniziato a
fare il video giuro ecco i ragazzi il
servizio è piaciuto l'azienda lasciato
commento mi piace anche a faccia di
facebook e come non divido trattener
descrizione sono titolari cityscape non
ci rivediamo lo prossimo
[Musica]
ma [ __ ] era quello era questo che
teneva la videocamera se avresti
discreti amici vi mettiamo un prossimo
vitobello ragazzi